we have the best vaccine in the world
the best medicines the best scientists
and we're learning more every single day
and we'll fight this variant with
scientific and
and knowledgeable actions and speed
not chaos and confusion president biden
on the fight against the omicron variant
yesterday putting his faith in vaccines
to do the job as scientists work to
learn more about the new coping strain
and how fast it spreads joining us now
is national institute of health director
francis collins sir why does it take two
weeks
to find out more about this mutation
well the two weeks is two different
things that are happening one is to look
and see in the real world in south
africa what is the real story about how
rapidly this can be transmitted and how
serious is the illness for people who
get infected with omicron that's going
to take a couple of weeks of close
observation to see whether people are
ending up in the hospital or not and
also because about 27 of south africans
are vaccinated has the vaccine provided
some protection we'll know more about
that in the next couple of weeks but the
other part of this is in the laboratory
we're basically synthesizing this
particular set of mutations and there's
more than 50 of them and then testing in
the lab whether in fact serum from
people who've been vaccinated is capable
of neutralizing omicron we'll probably
know that sometime near the end of next
week you just can't speed that stuff up
those are biological cycles that have to
happen when they happen jerome adams
former surgeon general with us last hour
here were his questions
that he would direct administration that
i want some answers for watch here
what i don't hear yet is what the
federal government is going to do to
prepare what are they going to do to
increase vaccine outreach what are we
going to do to continue to increase
testing availability we need to
understand that this isn't about
democrats versus republicans this is
america versus the virus so then when do
we get those answers sir
well jerome adams is a good friend of
mine and he's asking the right questions
and i think you're going to see later on
this week the president's going to make
a speech on thursday about a surge in
terms of getting vaccinations and
boosters into arms but let's recognize
the main holding thing holding that back
is not the availability of vaccines or
the evidence to support them it's
whether american public is ready to roll
up their sleeves and here's i've got to
say i've been serving three presidents
over 12 years and i'm proud of that it's
really unfortunate that politics has
gotten so mixed up in this if we can get
the politics out of it and look at the
public health needs maybe those 60
million americans who haven't gotten
vaccinated yet would see this is
something they want especially now with
omicron out there as the next threat one
of the things the president said
yesterday is that the mutation was
caused for concern but not panic and the
new york times today they had this piece
in them in their morning newsletter
which i always read it said that it is
possible that mutations make a virus
more fearsome but that it also
could make it weaker or cancel each
other out and so will we know that in
two weeks
i think we'll have a sense of that by
watching what happens in south africa
because there's lots of people getting
omicron right now there and we'll see
whether they are as sick as people
who've had delta or whether it could be
milder early indications maybe it's
milder but that was mostly looking at
young people so i'd be hesitant to call
it right now but that is a critical
question we should have more answers
soon i
i've been vaccinated i feel pretty good
about it
i'm reading these south african doctors
who said that these are mild cases
they cause fatigue and that's about it a
lot of people being treated at home i i
see no great cause for alarm based on
that that early reporting what am i
missing about this story
so i've been on zoom calls with the
leaders of the south african public
health system they're worried that that
may have been a premature declaration of
mildness of the illness because most of
the early cases were in college students
who tend not to get very sick anyway so
let's hold off on that before concluding
that this is not a virus that can cause
people to get sick enough to be in the
hospital we'll know more in a week or so
but i would be hesitant to declare those
early statements as the answer just yet
well
in a week or so we would love to have
you back so we can
learn more we appreciate your time thank
you so much sir
glad to come back any time thank you sir
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now